esta mañana han habido dos clases de
reacciones a ese ataque que se realizó
anoche en el área fronteriza entre irak
y siria del lado sirio conocido como abu
kamal y donde tienen presencia esas
milicias iraquíes con respaldo de irán
una de ellas ha criticado la respuesta
del presidente joe biden dicen que sus
acciones son similares a las de sus
anses antecesores y dicen que no tendría
que haber respondido de esta manera a
los ataques de estas milicias a las
cuales acusan de estar atacando
sistemáticamente tanto a la cercanía de
la embajada norteamericana en bagdad o
como también estos días atrás a esa base
con presencia estadounidense en el
aeropuerto de erbil la capital del
kurdistán iraquí en el norte de irak
pero hay otros que dan la bienvenida y
dicen que esta es una respuesta a esas
acciones de estas milicias a las cuales
siempre se ha dicho que no actuarían si
no tuvieran el respaldo de irán pero
también dicen y celebran que esté
ejerciendo de esta manera por un lado
tiende lazos a irán por la posible
negociación
y regresó al acuerdo nuclear pero al
mismo tiempo manda mensajes claros de
que no dejará que esas milicias pro
iraníes actúen en contra de sus
intereses dentro de ir a otros países de
la región